over at Werder Bremen the atmosphere is
less tense although this promises to be
a tough season we've come to find out
more time to leave the comfort of a
wicker beach chair and meet Bremen coach
Robin Hood earlier he gave up his job as
sporting director of the German Football
Association to rebuild the bremen squad
no easy task
the club has faltered badly in recent
years and is trying to regain its status
as purveyor of high-octane offensive
football and re-established themselves
as a fixture in European competitions
so where are vader Bremen at in 2013 in
the 2013 Vera Braman are a club in
transition we want to keep the old
traditional values but we mustn't let
them drag us down because it's a
completely different now than the way
it's run commercially and in football
terms - it's no longer the glory days of
the Champions League now we have a young
team and we're playing against other
clubs on equal footing murder isn't
really used to that but everyone's on
board now and moving in the same
direction images often say more than a
thousand words when I watched Raymond's
matches I get the sense every goal and
every victory is like a huge weight off
your shoulders immense and last funny
every time I feel really nervous every
time you always feel tense beforehand
you want to win it's not like other jobs
where you can say in evening I've
achieved this or that you have to wait
for the weekend you work all week
towards that and if you win you feel
relieved the week was worth it and you
achieved what you set out to do and it
was the default Gunawan Hut clapped when
I like long died that's what made you
give up the pleasant job as German
Football Association sporting director
to do this every week the stress always
in the line of fire always under
scrutiny what was the attraction the
exact total take me here exactly what
you just said the daily praise and daily
criticism no I got used to that over the
last decade and yes you get to the point
where you think do I really need all
this criticism but if you no longer want
the criticism you have to do without the
praise as well praise and criticism
always go hand in hand and I missed that
at first
and I also missed working in a team
field I'd find item team table see you
have a lot of experience as a coach
what's most useful for vertebrae my club
Hut Yiddish tattooing I think each job
taught me important things in Freiburg
of course I learned to work with young
talents and to carry the club's training
philosophy and also to be resilient when
you're at a position in the table where
you don't win anything for weeks in
labor Kuzon I definitely learned to deal
with personal crises coping was no
longer being popular and people suddenly
not being happy with you anymore
and the year with the German Football
Association helped me to see things a
little more relaxed way so each job has
played an important role three victories
and three defeats what's the mood in the
squad is there a sense that things are
slowly moving forward yeah there's
definitely been a noticeable development
we beaten three teams that are beatable
at the moment and we've lost the three
teams where it's no disgrace to lose
it's okay to lose oh it's not okay but
it happens had where do you draw
encouragement do bunch of the team
encourages play especially their
mentality at practice I get up in the
morning I'm really looking forward to
coming here I probably come much too
early and leave far too late thanks and
all the best don't you invite him Alice
Alice guten